the concept of texting was invented by
German engineer Fred hum hitting brand
which is just a fun name to say free Tom
Hillen Glen come here a Flay Tom please
in 1985 flea Tom developed the
foundations for short messaging service
also known as SMS not to be confused
with S&M which is a completely different
thing text messages used to have 160
character limit and cost about 50 cents
to send so you couldn't just blather on
about whatever random and completely
unimportant thing you're thinking about
at that very moment but today there is
no character limit and unlimited texting
plans are standard so you often get
bombarded with these yeah that's right
I'm calling you out every woman in the
world spoiler alert if your text can't
fit into lines then I'm not reading it
don't try to sneak around that rule by
sending 37 one-line text either make no
confusion this isn't a conversation just
because it says delivered doesn't mean I
willingly accept you know how men text
with these few words as possible you'd
be amazed at what you can accomplish yo
hey hungry yeah sushi where sake house
cool ate Cole Cole in 12 words 11 if the
name of the restaurant hadn't been - we
established a directive negotiated the
terms of dinner and execute a timetable
salutations included you know you won't
find in that thread any emoticons or
emojis ladies gotta cool it with those
two okay she's a little to-do list when
Friedhelm developed texting over 30
years ago he had not foreseen the pure
evil that his technology would
eventually lead to the group text group
text is kind of like the open mic of
text messages a lot of people you don't
mind hanging out with one on one but
when they get together kill me then
there's that one number you don't have
stored in your phone you have no idea
who the hell it is and they're just
sending picture jokes look pal
don't let the haha lol go to your head
you're not funny
okay it's just sad it's just dated
material and finally parents you don't
have to sign your text love mom and love
dad I know who's sending the text okay
you look like fools FYI
alright clearly you have your own phone
I have your number stored duh little
dude fleet I'm helling but no I'm not
gonna lie having a ball just saying his
name give a shot fleet hub hilling blood
little did he know three decades ago his
technology would eventually lead to the
decline
of communication as we know it remember
say it don't text it hey guys thanks
again for watching be sure to follow on
social like favor and share
check out more episodes weddings used to
be the celebration of couples marriage
with friends family and loved ones today
weddings are an event kind of like
WrestleMania because people don't just
get married and throw a party anymore
no now they got to make a giant
spectacle out of the whole thing
[Music]